these days American presidents travel
around the country on Air Force one but
in the 1940s there was no Air Force one
actually there wasn't even a US Air
Force they were still part of the army
Franklin D Roosevelt was the first
sitting US president to fly in an
airplane back in 1943 but for most of
his presidency he used a very different
form of travel this is the ferdinand
magellan officially known as u.s. car
number one 120 tons of armor plated
bulletproof railcar the railcar is the
heaviest u.s. real car ever built they
had to build special trucks just to
support the extra weight the reason it
only weighs up to hundred eighty-five
thousand pounds is that was a weight
limit for US railroads bridges and
trestles at that time so the entire car
is not armored proof only where the
president is the car has five eighths
inch thick bulletproof steel through
most of the car up to at this point here
you see where the rivets change from
double rivets the single rivets regular
steel here versus the bulletproof steel
here so there's bulletproofing there's
12 ply laminated glass there are two
escape hatches in the car to get the
president out it was never painted red
white and blue like Air Force One it was
always painted Pullman green when they
had to park it somewhere they would hide
it with other Pullman railcar so it was
basically hiding in plain sight after
Roosevelt's death President Truman used
the Magellan for a while asking the
engineers to get the train up to 80
miles an hour if they could before
television was a way to reach the masses
Truman toured America in this train
campaigning for re-election traveling
tens of thousands of miles between tiny
stations known as whistle stops and
making up to eight speeches a day and it
worked
the famous moment where he held up the
newspaper that wrongly announced his
defeat that was just there on the back
of this train now in 1928
air conditioning was accomplished by ice
there are ice bunkers in the car blocks
of ice were put in there and ceiling
fans across the whole car would then
blow the cold air as it dropped down so
now we're heading into the armored part
of the car where the
stayed here we have the dining room all
the rooms in the car had a phone in them
when the car was underway the phones
were hooked up to a radio car called the
general minor when they were in stations
they were hot-wired into the bones in
the station this is a that's the
president would use he could sign papers
this is what the windows look like this
is 12 ply laminated glass about three
inches thick so all the windows from
this point to the rear of the car are
sealed you cannot take them out which is
why they have air-conditioning
staterooms see here this is the
president's quarters the president has a
fixed bed giving him a little bit of
extra legroom that is what a commode
chair looks like the back folds down
there's a sink and that seat folds up to
be a toilet underneath the wheelchair it
was built specifically for Roosevelt's
use in this car so you get up and down
the narrow hallway here we have the
presidential bathroom and the first of
the two escape hatches are here what
would have been a window has been
converted to a steel plate that they
could push out and they could get the
president out that way if they needed to
well it looks like a soap dish hanging
by the door here is actually a cigar
holder Roosevelt was sitting there in
smoke cigars here we have the
Observation Lounge of the car that's
where presidents would sit in the back
of the car and watch the rails past
behind I'm entertained the guests that
were on the car with them we also have
the second escape hatch and this was
fashioned from a submarine it was
designed if the car was ever knocked
over on its side
they could open this door and go out it
this door leads to the rear platform the
door alone weighs 1,500 pounds that's
about half the weight of the car that
most people come to visit our museum in
its passion after a bank vault out
here's the rear platform this is where
presidents would give their speeches
when Truman ascended as a presidency
after Roosevelt died
pretty much lived in this car for a few
months as you did across the campaign's
trail and he made more than 350
Whistlestop speeches from this back
platform that's what allowed him to
connect with the American people
of course air travel became easier and
cheaper and safer and eventually the
ferdinand magellan fell out of use
nowadays it's a museum piece but in an
era where the Trump train is just a
metaphor it's interesting to note that
there were other presidents whose train
was
a little more real America as a country
except for certain parts of the country
doesn't embrace rails the way that we
used to this piece is historic it is
unique it is
harkening back to a simpler place in
time and a simpler pace of life and
that's what I wish we could kind of get
a little piece of that back still keep
our cell phones I'm not giving that up
thank you to everyone at the Gold Coast
Railway Museum pull down the description
for more about them and about the
ferdinand magellan
you